welcome to the hubermann lab podcast
where we discuss science
and science-based tools for everyday
life
i'm andrew huberman and i'm a professor
of neurobiology and ophthalmology
at stanford school of medicine today we
are going to talk about
science-based protocols for sleep
mood learning nutrition
exercise of various kinds strength and
endurance and hypertrophy
and we are going to talk about some
protocols that relate to creativity
we're going to talk about behavioral
protocols supplement-based protocols
all science backed by quality
peer-reviewed literature
the reason that we're holding this
episode now is that in the recent
previous episodes we've covered some
pretty intense and in-depth topics we've
talked about vision
and how we see and how to get better at
seeing and how to maintain vision
we've talked about hearing and balance
we've talked about chemical sensing
and we had a guest episode that covered
a lot of information about
new and emerging technologies in
neuroscience as well as mental health
that was the interview episode with dr
carl diceroth
so given that we've covered so much
detailed information
in the previous 27 episodes of the
hubermann lab podcast
i decided that we would hold office
hours office hours in the university
setting are when students
come to the professor's office or you
meet outdoors on campus
or in the classroom to review the
material and questions from lecture
in more detail now unfortunately we
don't have the opportunity to meet
face to face in real life but
nonetheless you've been sending your
questions putting them in the comments
section
on youtube etc and i've prepared a
number of answers to the questions that
have shown up
most frequently now in order to provide
context and structure to the way that we
will address
these questions i've arranged the
science and science-based protocols
that relate to various aspects of life
such as
mood exercise sleep waking anxiety
creativity etc
into the context of a day selecting the
unit of a day
in order to deliver this science
information and protocols
is not a haphazard decision on my part
it's actually the case that every cell
in our body every organ in our body and
our brain
is modulated or changes across the
24-hour day in a very
regular and predictable rhythm and it's
no coincidence that the earth spins once
on its axis
every 24 hours these two things are
coordinated by virtue of genes and
different
proteins and things that are expressed
in every cell of your body
and so selecting the unit of the day is
not just a practical one but it's one
that's related
to our deeper biology you may have heard
in my
interview episode with dr carl diceroth
that
he himself in order to juggle a
tremendous
workload a full-time clinical practice a
lab of 40 plus people
a family of five children etc
breaks up his life into units of days
and so today we are going to
further dissect the day as a unit that
one can manage
and manage extremely well and in fact
can optimize
so we're basically going to talk about
how to leverage
science-based protocols and when i say
science i mean quality
peer-reviewed science published in
excellent journals
we're going to talk about how to take
that science convert it into specific
protocols
that break up along the course of a
single day and direct
certain types of behaviors in order to
optimize the various features of life
i will couch this in the context of what
i do
across a daily 24-hour rhythm that
doesn't mean that you have to follow
this schedule
at all or even in part it's just by way
of example
any number of the different things that
i described could be applied to any
number of different schedules or
frameworks
but if there's one truth that applies to
all of us is that we
all have to exist within the context of
this 24-hour rhythm that we all possess
so that's what we'll focus on before we
begin i'd like to emphasize that this
podcast is separate from my teaching and
research roles at stanford
it is however part of my desire and
effort to bring zero cost to consumer
information about science
and science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme i'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast
our first sponsor is roka roka makes
eyeglasses and sunglasses that
i believe are the very highest quality
possible developed by two all-american
swimmers from stanford
roca sunglasses and eyeglasses were
developed with their intention to create
sunglasses and eyeglasses that could be
worn anywhere so while
exercising or while working at home
while driving
the reason i like roka glasses so much
is that first of all they're extremely
lightweight
the optical clarity of the lenses is
excellent and so i
often just forget that i even have them
on when i'm outside and i'm wearing
sunglasses
they have this really terrific feature
which is that i can move in and out of
shadows or the cloud cover can change
and i can see perfectly well the entire
time you know many eyeglasses and
sunglasses that i've tried
depending on the what we call the
ambient lighting conditions the local
lighting conditions outside
i have to take them off or put them back
on it's really annoying for me but with
roka glasses
somehow i'm assuming because they really
understand the science of the visual
system
the eyeglasses and sunglasses work
seamlessly with whatever environment
you're in so that's absolutely terrific
another thing about roka eyeglasses and
sunglasses is that their aesthetic is
really terrific
you know i don't think i'm alone in
saying that many performance glasses as
they're called
end up making people look like a cyborg
but the sunglasses are of the sort that
you know you can wear while running or
biking or
driving or out to dinner i don't
typically wear sunglasses while out to
dinner but you get the idea you can wear
them anywhere
and they look very natural they have a
huge number of different styles to
select
from if you'd like to try roka glasses
you can go to
roka that's roka.com and enter the code
huberman to save 20 off your first order
that's roca roka.com
and enter the code huberman at checkout
today's podcast is also brought to us by
inside tracker
insidetracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and dna
to help you better understand your body
and help you reach your health goals
i've long been a believer in getting
regular blood work done for the simple
reason
that many of the factors that impact
your immediate and long-term health
can only be analyzed from a quality
blood test
with inside tracker it alleviates a
specific problem that's associated with
most if not all of the other blood tests
and dna tests out there
and that problem is you get information
back about the levels of various things
metabolic factors hormones etc
but you don't know what to do with that
information with inside tracker they
have this terrific dashboard that allows
you
to both see your levels of hormones
metabolic factors and the rest
but also it suggests specific things
that you can do with your nutrition your
exercise and lifestyle and so forth
in order to bring those levels into the
ranges that are best for your immediate
and long-term health
in addition they make the whole process
of getting your blood and dna taken
very easy they'll even come to your home
to take the sample
if you'd like to try inside tracker you
can go to insidetracker.com
huberman and if you do that you'll get
25 off
any of inside tracker's plans just use
the code huberman at checkout that's
insidetracker.com huberman to get 25
off any of insidetrackers plans today's
episode is also brought to us by helix
sleep
helix sleep makes mattresses and pillows
that are ideally matched to your sleep
needs
i started sleeping on a helix mattress
about eight months ago
and i can honestly say it's the best
sleep that i've ever had in my entire
life
and that's because the mattress was
actually designed for me and you can
have a mattress designed for you
if you go to helixsleep.com they have
this free very brief two-minute quiz
that asks you a number of questions like
do you sleep on your side or your back
do you tend to run
warm while you sleep or you tend to get
cold in the middle of the night
maybe you don't know the answers to
those questions and that's fine too
after taking that quiz they will match
you to a specific mattress
that's ideal for your sleep needs i
matched to the so-called dusk mattress
the usk
because i wanted a mattress that was not
too firm not too soft
as i mentioned i absolutely love it if
you're interested in upgrading your
mattress you can go to helixsleep.com
huberman take their two minute sleep
quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress
and you'll get up to 200 off your
mattress order and two free pillows they
also make these terrific pillows
they have a 10-year warranty and you get
to try out the mattress for a hundred
nights risk-free if you don't like it
they'll come pick it up
and they'll take it away but i think
you'll love it i certainly love mine
again if you're interested you can go to
helixsleep.com
huberman for up to 200 off and two free
pillows
so let's talk about how to apply quality
peer-reviewed science to your day
and how to optimize everything from
sleep to learning
creativity meal timing etc
as i mentioned earlier i'm going to do
this in the context of my day
and what i typically do however the
specific protocols for
any number of different things sleep
relaxation meal timing exercise etc
any one or all of those could be
rearranged to suit your specific needs
i'm going to tell you what i do from
morning until waking and even what i do
while i sleep in order to optimize my
sleep
so let's start with getting up in the
morning
now for me i tend to wake up sometime
around 6 a.m
6 30 sometimes as late as 7 00 a.m i
don't typically sleep much later than
7 a.m the first thing i do after i wake
up
is i take the pen that's on my
nightstand and the pad of paper on my
nightstand
and i write down the time in which i
woke up
now i do sleep with my phone in my room
i realize this is considered a sin
and has certain hazards associated with
it but i put my phone on airplane mode
about an
hour before i go to sleep and then i set
my alarm typically for 6 30 a.m
and some days the alarm wakes me up
other days i wake up before the alarm
and yes some days the alarm goes off and
i hit snooze a few times
and then usually by 7 am i am up and out
of bed
the reason for writing down what time i
wake up
is because i want to know that average
wake-up time
that average wake-up time informs what's
called
my temperature minimum it tells me when
my body temperature was lowest
the temperature minimum is the time
in each 24-hour cycle that your body
temperature is lowest
i don't sleep with a thermometer in my
mouth or elsewhere and i don't think you
should either
instead i know that the lowest
temperature that my body will be at
across the 24 hour cycle tends to be
two hours before my typical wake up time
and i want to know that number it's
called our temperature
minimum so if you're somebody that
typically wakes up at 8am
then your temperature minimum is
sometime around 6am remember the
temperature minimum is a
time in the 24-hour cycle i don't care
what my
actual temperature is i care when my
lowest temperature is and i know
that that lowest temperature is
approximately two hours before
my average wake-up time so i highly
recommend
that you write down when you wake up or
track that in some way
that works for you and use that as a
reference point to determine your
temperature minimum
we will return to the temperature
minimum and how you can
leverage the temperature minimum for
several things
shifting your clock shifting your
circadian sleep schedule and wake
schedule
also for shifting your eating schedule
etc we will return to that
but even if you don't travel even if you
don't care about things like jet lag
even if you sleep fabulously all year
round
never have a poor night sleep knowing
your temperature minimum that time when
your temperature is at its lowest point
is a valuable thing to know the second
thing i do after i wake up
is to get into forward ambulation which
is just nerd speak for
taking a walk now i have a dog and
as many of you know he's a bulldog and
he doesn't really like to walk
especially not in the morning but for
humans
and for animals there's a phenomenon
whereby when we generate
our own forward motion forward
ambulation
visual images pass by us on our eyes
so-called optic flow and for those of
you that are low vision or no vision
the same phenomenon occurs in the
auditory system sounds pass
by us in so-called auditory flow
getting into a mode of forward
ambulation
and especially experiencing visual flow
has a powerful effect on the nervous
system
the effect it has is essentially to
quiet
or reduce the amount of neural activity
in this brain structure called the
amygdala
amygdala means almond and many of you
have probably heard about the amygdala
for its role in anxiety and fear and
threat detection and indeed
the amygdala is part of the network in
the brain that generates
feelings of fear and threat and anxiety
it does a bunch of other things too but
that's one of its primary functions
there are now at least half a dozen
quality papers
published in quality peer-reviewed
journals that show that
forward ambulation walking or biking or
running
and generating optic flow in particular
has this incredible property of lowering
activity in the amygdala and thereby
reducing levels of anxiety
there are two papers that i'd like to
highlight in particular
that relate to this phenomenon the first
one was published in the journal neuron
and the title of this paper is whole
brain functional ultrasound imaging that
just means they have a cool technique to
evaluate the activity of structures in
the brain across the entire brain
reveals brain modules for visual motor
integration
what they found in this study and i
should mention the first author is masse
this comes from
bhoton raska's group this was work done
in mice
but i will talk about other species in a
moment what they found was essentially
that
when these mice walk forward and their
eyes move from side to side which is a
natural consequence of moving forward
so-called optic flow is flowing past
their
eyes many brain areas are activated
increase in their level of firing
but the amygdala in particular reduced
its levels of firing
that's a very interesting finding but it
is in mice however
another paper eye movement intervention
enhances extinction via amygdala
deactivation
was published in the the journal of
neuroscience a strong journal
and shows that again these eye movements
these lateral eye movements from side to
side
reduce activity levels in this
fear slash threat slash anxiety center
in the brain the amygdala
now those are eye movements they didn't
specifically look at
forward ambulation and yet other papers
have looked at forward ambulation and we
know that forward ambulation
walking forward generates the sorts of
eye movements
that cause optic flow and reductions in
amygdala activation
so for me this process of taking a walk
each morning isn't about
exercise it's not about burning calories
it's not
about any of that it's really about
getting into optic flow
and reducing the levels of amygdala
activation
now i don't have anxiety at least i
don't have chronic anxiety or
generalized anxiety
i tend to have a lot of energy but at
these points in the morning
i'm not very energetic sometimes i'm
sort of shuffling more than i'm walking
in fact and costello is almost always
shuffling and i'm
almost always trying to drag him first
thing in the morning but
that walk is a particularly important
protocol each day because it really
serves to push my neurology in the
direction that i'd like it to go which
is
alert but not anxious and it's kind of a
fine line sometimes especially as events
surface throughout the day emails come
in text messages come in
get bombarded with a number of things i
want to be alert and responsive
i want to be able to focus but i don't
want to feel anxious or
reactive to these things so the
forward ambulation and this optic flow
is the way that
i ensure based on quality peer-reviewed
data that my amygdala activation is
slightly suppressed
now at the same time i also want the
alertness
i want alert and focused i don't just
want to be sleepy or super
super relaxed i want to have a high
degree of focus and alertness because
i'm soon going to move into about of
work i need to lean into the day
so in order to do that i make sure that
the
walking is done outdoors that might be
sort of a duh
but many people get up and start moving
around their house their apartment and
they don't go anywhere
and just walking around inside it will
generate some optic flow but nothing
like the sort of optic flow that you can
generate in
larger environments like out-of-doors
environments if you can't get outdoors
doing it indoors
is perfectly fine but it's not going to
have the same magnitude
of positive effect now in order to get
the alertness
i do it outdoors because i also want
sunlight in my eyes
i know many of you have heard me talk
about this ad nauseam on various
podcasts in this podcast
but getting sunlight in your eyes first
thing
in the morning is absolutely vital to
mental and physical health
it is perhaps the most important thing
that any and all of us
can and should do in order to promote
metabolic well-being
promote the positive functioning of your
hormone system get your mental health
steering in the right direction there
are a number of reasons for this but
before i get into those reasons let me
just emphasize what the protocol
is the protocol is get outdoors
ideally with no sunglasses if you can do
that safely even if there's cloud cover
more photons light information are
coming through that cloud cover then
would be coming from a very bright
indoor bulb
so getting outdoors is absolutely key
how long should you do this it's going
to depend on the brightness of the
environment it's going to depend on a
number of different factors
two minutes would be a minimum 10
minutes would be even better
and if you can 30 minutes would be
fantastic
now it's a very bright day or you know
you live in a place where there's bright
sunlight clear day on a snow field
you would only need something like 60
seconds but most people aren't living
in those sorts of conditions so getting
outside for a 10 minute walk or a 15
minute
walk will basically ensure that you're
getting adequate stimulation of these
neurons in the eye that are called the
melanopsin
intrinsically photosensitive ganglion
cells i know that's a mouthful these are
neurons that don't care about shapes of
objects or the motion of objects
these are neurons that convey to the
brain that it's daytime and it's time to
be alert
and it sets in motion a huge number of
biological cascades within
every cell and organ of your body from
your liver to your gut to your heart to
your brain
it really sets things down the right
path
early in the day we experience a
natural and healthy bump in a hormone
called cortisol
cortisol comes from the amygdala that
cortisol as i mentioned is healthy and
normal
and promotes wakefulness it actually
promotes a healthy immune system
so i know you've heard that stress and
cortisol disrupt the immune system but
not the
short little pulse of cortisol that you
get each morning it's very important
that that
pulse of cortisol arrive early in the
day
i want to emphasize this again it's very
important that that pulse of cortisol
arrive
early in the day and that pulse of
cortisol is going to happen once every
24 hours
no matter what it's going to happen and
you get to time it how do you time it
primarily by when you view bright
sunlight
or bright light of another kind and
we'll talk about that in a moment
so you want that cortisol pushed early
if you wake up before the sun
comes out it's fine to turn on
artificial lights but then you would
want to get outside as soon as you can
to get this art this excuse me natural
light stimulation of your eyes
and it does have to be to your eyes just
a really
drill down into the details for a moment
you don't want to stare directly at the
sun or any light that's so bright that
it feels painful if it's
if you feel like you have to close your
eyes or blink please do you don't want
to damage your retinas
the point here is to get the sunlight
indirectly
it's going to essentially be scattered
everywhere through the cloud cover
but you know from looking at us at a
flashlight directly into that flashlight
versus looking at the beam that
flashlight generates on the ground that
if you're standing in the shade you're
going to get less of that sunlight than
you are if you're out in an open field
so this is why the time outside it's
going to need to vary depending on your
particular environment but do your best
to do this every day if you miss a day
no big deal but try not to miss
more than one day otherwise your mental
and physical health will start to suffer
and doing this each day costs nothing
it's just time you can combine it with
the forward ambulation with the walk and
the optic flow that i talked about
before
and that's what i do each morning to
generate a sense of alertness in my body
and brain to generate a sense of calm
yet alert
and that's also what i do with costello
with my bulldog
people have asked me do these same
mechanisms apply to animals
well the reality is many of these
mechanisms were actually discovered in
animals
and then were tested in humans and
verified that they also exist in humans
not always sometimes it was the reverse
where they were tested first in humans
and then brought to animals but indeed
your dog
your horse uh you know i don't know what
other animals are out there they need
this
now if you have a hamster or a nocturnal
animal
the reason why they like to run on their
wheels at night is because they're
nocturnal
they don't like being in the light light
actually causes them to freeze
right actually if you are into aquaria
you like fish
they always say don't over feed your
fish you'll kill the fish that's true
but guess what the fastest way to kill a
fish is
to keep the lights on 24 hours a day
they also need circadian
circadian rhythms these 24-hour rhythms
so
we'll do an entire month at some point
about pet health but
meanwhile get that morning sunlight so
now we have our first protocol
which is to write down the time of day
that you wake up the second protocol is
to get
take a walk first thing in the morning
and the third protocol
is woven in with that walk at least for
me which is
to get that sunlight exposure now if you
can't get sunlight exposure you
absolutely can't
i don't necessarily recommend buying one
of these dawn alarm lights
they i'm sorry to say this but they're
just
vastly overpriced relative to what they
are they're basically a bright led
i instead use i have a pad that's a 930
lux light pad
i think it was designed for drawing
those are available
at a fraction of the cost that a that a
morning light
simulator would provide and yet it's
really uh
bright enough at least for me i tend to
put it on my desk while i work each
morning
so here's a principle that you can
leverage
if you want to be alert view bright
lights and make those lights above you
they tend to or
in front of you if you want to go to
sleep soon or you
don't want to be awake for whatever
reason try and eliminate your exposure
to light
and this again is not about exposure of
the skin
to light this is about exposure of your
eyes of your neural retinas
to light for those of you that are
concerned about blue light
i want to emphasize that blue light is
precisely the wavelength of light that
is optimal for stimulating these neurons
in your eye
which set your circadian rhythms
properly so you don't want to shield
yourself from blue light early in the
day
or throughout the day or anytime you
want to be awake in fact that could have
a number of
detrimental consequences fortunately all
those consequences are going to be
reversible
after a short period of time of making
sure that you don't wear your blue
blockers during the day please
the time to wear blue blockers if you do
is at night and in the evening when
you're headed towards sleep
my colleague samuel hatar who is head of
the chronobiology unit at the national
institutes of mental health
has spoken about this before on my
instagram we held an instagram live and
i said
samuel what do you think about blue
blockers and he said i don't think
that's a good idea at all
unless it's really late at night and
you're in a bright environment
and you're trying to limit the amount of
bright light that that impacts the eyes
eliminating specific wavelengths of
light in samura's opinion and also in my
opinion
is not a natural thing for the visual
system and the brain to experience
some people get headaches while they
work on the computer
all day or staring at screens and so
they get blue blockers thinking that's
going to protect them from their
headaches
however any protection that you get from
headaches from blue blockers is going to
be
minimal in comparison to what's really
going on there which is that people are
viewing devices and screens up close
for too many hours throughout the 24
hour cycle
a better remedy would be to step away
from that computer from time to time and
to make sure that you can look far off
into the distance ideally
a distance longer than 20 feet like view
a horizon go out on a balcony things of
that sort take a walk around
get into optic flow so if you're into
blue blockers
make sure you're only wearing them in
the late evening and at night
i personally don't wear blue blockers at
all i prefer to just control my light
viewing behavior by doing this
i do the other form of circadian control
which is to dim
the lights and i do that because dimming
the lights and setting them lower in the
environment
sets up the brain and body for sleep
much better than simply just
wearing some blue light blue blockers
excuse me
and please know if you do wear blue
blockers that if the light in your
environment is bright enough
it doesn't matter if you're blocking out
the blues these cells in the eye will
respond to
other wavelengths of light so i have no
vendetta against the blue blockers
and you know i fully expect the blue
block anistas to come after me with
i guess blue blockers but as you do that
please understand
that the biology points in the direction
of get a lot of bright light throughout
the day including blue light and at
night
just limit the total amount of overall
light that you're exposed to including
from screens
so then costello and i get back from our
walk sometimes that walk was 10 minutes
sometimes it was 60 minutes
depending on how slowly costello was
walking that day
indeed many mornings i'm the guy
carrying his bulldog back up the hill
my neighbors know me so well they know
costello so well that they've since
stopped pulling over and asking if the
dog is okay
sometimes they'll ask if i'm okay
nonetheless
we get back i give him his food i give
him his water
and i give me my water i'm a big
believer based on
quality peer-reviewed data that
hydration is essential
for mental performance now i confess i
don't really like drinking
big glasses or big jugs of water first
thing in the morning i don't know why
but my thirst doesn't tend to kick in
first thing you may be different either
way i
force myself essentially to drink at
least 16 and
most days 32 ounces of water i also put
a little bit of sea salt in the water
as many of you know neurons require
ionic flow what that means is neurons
need sodium they need magnesium and they
need potassium in order to function
we do tend to get dehydrated at night
even if the day is not very hot i try
and top off or i try and
make sure that i'm hydrated early in the
day before i begin
any work so i make myself drink this
water
with a little bit of sea salt how much
sea salt if you really want to get
detailed that you i suppose it's about
half a teaspoon it's not much
that's what i do and i drink that more
or less room temperature
i find that drinking really cold water
first thing in the day kind of like
cramps up my insides
so i don't do that at that point i start
thinking about
and fantasizing about and craving
caffeine but i don't drink that caffeine
yet
i purposely delay my caffeine intake
to 90 minutes to 120 minutes after i
wake up
of course i know when i wake up because
i wrote it down although it's pretty
easy to commit to memory
the reason i delay caffeine is because
one of the factors
that induces a sense of sleepiness is
the buildup of adenosine
or as some people call it adenosine
in our system the buildup of adenosine
accumulates the longer we are awake
so when i wake up in the morning when
you wake up in the morning your
adenosine levels
are likely to be very low however
caffeine is an adenosine blocker it's
actually a competitive antagonist for
you aficionados it sort of parks in the
receptor that adenosine
normally would park at and prevents
adenosine from
acting on that receptor that's why you
feel more alert because it's essentially
blocking
the effect of this sleepiness factor
that we all create called adenosine
the reason for delaying caffeine intake
90 minutes to two hours after waking
is i want to make sure that i don't have
a late afternoon or even early afternoon
crash from caffeine
one of the best ways to ensure a
caffeine crash
is to drink a bunch of caffeine block
all those adenosine receptors
and then by early or late afternoon when
that caffeine starts to wear off and
gets dislodged from the receptors
a lower level of adenosine is able to
create a greater level of sleepiness
it took me years to figure this out i
used to wake up and i'd think oh i don't
want to drink caffeine too close to
bedtime so i'm going to start drinking
my caffeine really early
i let my cortisol naturally come up in
the morning
i avoid drinking caffeine until about 90
minutes or two hours
after waking and when i do that i find
that i don't experience the afternoon
crash
at least i don't experience that crash
unless i do something foolish like
ingest far too much food at lunch or i
stay up all night the night before
but provided i don't do anything foolish
like that delaying caffeine in 90
minutes to two hours
optimizes this relationship between
adenosine and wakefulness and sleepiness
in a way that really provides a nice
consistent arc
of energy throughout the day and brings
energy down as i'm headed toward
sleep and falling asleep my primary
objective early in the day
is to get into a mode of being focused
yet alert so that i can get work done
i found that the best way for me to
achieve that state is through fasting
so i don't eat anything until about 11am
or 12 noon i'm not absolutely religious
about it there are days when i'll have a
few brazil nuts or
a spoonful or three of almond butter for
instance
but most days i'm not doing that i'm
just not eating
anything i'm drinking some caffeine
caffeine source for me is yerba mate
guayusa tea
those are my preferred sources i tend to
avoid coffee these days occasionally i
have a cup but most often
i stick to the teas i drink water as
much as i feel like i need to
and want to and i also drink my athletic
greens which is compatible at least for
me
with fasting let's talk about
why fasting works to create this
heightened state of alertness
yet calm brain state fasting
increases levels of adrenaline also
called epinephrine in the brain and body
and when our levels of epinephrine and
adrenaline are increased
we learn better we can focus better
there's terrific data supporting that
you don't want epinephrine aka
adrenaline
too high that feels like stress and
panic
you get jittery you can't focus but in
its optimal range
adrenaline really provides a heightened
sense of focus and the ability to
encode meaning bring in and retain
remember
information and so since my job is
mainly a cerebral one where i'm writing
grants and working on papers etc
i fast in the early part of the day i
mentioned
ingesting things like guyusa or yerba
mate
or in my case athletic greens many
people ask in fact there's a whole
community in discussion boards etc and
youtube comments on the internet about
what breaks a fast and what doesn't the
fact of the matter is
that's going to be highly individual
because it's going to depend
on how sensitive your blood sugar is you
know
and more more accurately it's going to
depend on things like your insulin
sensitivity
so for instance if you're somebody who
gets up in the morning
hydrates and goes out for a six mile run
you could probably eat a jar of almond
butter
and still be what's called fat fasted
your insulin levels will still be very
low because even though that
is a large volume of almond butter even
to me
and costello that large number of
calories come from a source that doesn't
increase blood sugar very much and
insulin very much
now i'm not suggesting you do that but
what i just described is a vastly
different situation than somebody that
ate their last meal at 2 a.m
and that meal was essentially a feast
and
for that person fasting until 10 or 11
a.m
their blood sugar might still actually
be pretty high or even low-ish such that
they might eat one almond and it would
bump them out of fasting
so you get the idea it's going to depend
on your recent
eating history your blood sugar history
your glycogen
stores etc so if anyone tells you
that breaks a fast or that doesn't
that's kind of silly would one grain of
sugar break your fast no
would an entire tablespoon of sugar
break your fast yes you'll get a big
blip in
blood sugar and insulin from that
however how long that lasts how long it
breaks your fast will depend on
how glycogen depleted you are and a
number of other factors
so for me i just keep it fairly simple i
ingest water
caffeine from yerba mate and guayusa and
i drink my athletic greens with some
lemon juice in it
that constitutes my fasting
and there are days when i do all those
things there are days when i do none of
those things although most days i would
say about 300 355 days out of the year
i'm ingesting water caffeine and
athletic greens
during this period of fasting early in
the day and that's the period of time
when i do my work
one interesting fact about yerba mate
and guayusa teas is that they increase
release of something called glp-1
glp-1 is related to glucagon
glucagon is a hormone that you can sort
of think about
as opposite to insulin and blood sugar
it's more complex than that but
glp-1 has a couple of positive
properties one is it
increases lipolysis and mobilization of
body fat stores so burning of fat
in fact there are now a number of
clinical trials that are achieving good
success and there are drugs out there
only available by prescription which
mimic glp1
and are being used to treat quite
successfully
certain types of diabetes and obesity
now i'm not diabetic nor am i trying to
shed a ton of body fat but
i figure as long as i'm fasting and as
long as i like yerba mate in guayusa
which i do
they're delicious i'll tell you which
type i use in a moment
i might as well increase my glp-1
because it's probably not as good as
getting out and doing some cardio work
but
nonetheless if i'm fasted increasing
glp1 in my system
i'm going to be alert from the caffeine
the adrenaline etc
and i'm going to be burning body fat
while i'm doing my work so for me it's
just an efficient
biochemically rational or i should say
grounded in quality biochemistry
sort of approach yerba mate comes in a
lot of different forms there are a lot
of different brands out there etc
i don't have any relationship whatsoever
in a business sense to any of these
brands
some of them are very smoky
i just because of something in my
genetic makeup or i don't know maybe it
was
some sort of y chromosome associated
lesion early in life
but i don't like smoky flavors so i'm
not a
gouda cheese guy i don't like smoky
stuff you may love it
but i tend to avoid smoky tasting mates
instead there's a particular brand that
i just found on the internet called anna
park i don't know anna i don't know if
she has a park and i certainly don't
know what anna park is
but for me that's the best tasting yerba
mate again i don't
have any relationship to them but it's
affordable in the context of yerba mate
and it's the one that i use and i should
mention along the lines of affordability
and glp-1
is there's a nice feature of yerba mate
which is if you
put it in a filter or a metal strainer
and you pour
hot water over it and then drink it keep
the the leaves the yerba mate leaves can
be used over and over again it seems
that the glp-1
stimulating aspects of mate actually are
enhanced
with subsequent pour-overs so there's
something interesting about these teas
that my
tea aficionado friends tell me allows
the tea to release more of some of the
beneficial compounds
by reusing the tea leaves now eventually
it'll grow mold and other sorts of
disgusting things
you don't really want to run that
experiment i would say you can use it
for
a day or two before it starts to go bad
but that's a feature that will extend
the life of
whatever yerba mate you happen to use if
you decide to use it
and that's certainly what i do next i
want to talk about what i'm doing while
i'm drinking all this yerba mate because
i'm not just sitting there thinking
about all the glp-1 circulating in my
system
i'm working a couple of things for
optimizing workspace that are grounded
in
neuroscience and physiology i've talked
before about the fact that
when our eyes are directed upward
literally when our eyelids are open
no surprise there and when our eyes are
directed upward
it creates a state of heightened
alertness and
this has a relationship to the brainstem
neurons that
create alertness and their
control over the muscles of the eye and
believe it or not the eye lids
now it's not the case that if you are
absolutely exhausted and you need to
feel more alert
that looking upward is going to make you
feel wide awake
although it will help support your
levels of alertness
the point here is that you can optimize
your workstation
in a physical way that leverages this
aspect of the visual system
and your level of alertness since most
of us want to be awake while we're
working
try and position your screen or your
tablet
whatever device you happen to be working
on at least at eye level
and ideally slightly higher if you think
about it most people are not doing this
most people are looking down at their
computer or tablet
or are angling their eyes at their
screen at about 30 degrees
that is not going to support heightened
states of alertness and optimal
attention
in fact the opposite relationship
between eye position
and alertness is also true when we look
down when our eyelids
are slightly closed it tends to decrease
our levels of alertness and increase our
levels of sleepiness
i really want to emphasize this that
there's a bi-directional or reciprocal
relationship between the brain stem
areas that control alertness and the
eyes meaning how alert you are controls
how open or close your eyes are no
surprise there
but also that how open and upward
directed your eyes are will increase
your levels of alertness and if your
eyes are pointed downward and your
eyelids are hooded like they're slowly
closing like costellos are always are
you'll feel more sleepy especially if
you're somebody who tends to have that
mid-morning sleepiness or mid-morning
crash
so what i do is i have a standing desk
but i also prop the computer up
such that it's at least at eye level and
i haven't figured out yet how to
develop a workstation where the computer
is above me
i think the only way to really do that
is actually to tilt one's body back but
actually that's not
a good idea either they have done
studies recording from areas of the
brain associated with alertness areas
like locus
ceruleus and the so-called reticular
activating system they found is that
depending on how reclined you are or
upright you are
you will decrease with reclining and
increase
with sitting forward your levels of
alertness so
body posture and whether or not you're
upright or reclining
will impact your levels of alertness in
the predictable ways
and where you position your eyes whether
or not your eyes are upright
so to speak looking up or directly
forward or looking down
will dictate whether or not you are
feeling more alert
or more sleepy respectively so try and
arrange a workstation or a position
of your body in your chair or your
standing desk whatever it is
that allows you to work with a
heightened state of alertness
this is really really key for me because
i found that when i would sit down
not only when my hip flexors start to
get sore i feel tight in the back etc
but if i was staring down at my screen
all day
or even for short periods of the day i
would start to feel sleepy and i
couldn't figure out what was going on i
also thought maybe i needed glasses i do
wear readers at night but
it was really a problem and simply by
getting the screen directly in front of
me at eye level
it's been completely transformative so
we're now at the
description of my day in these protocols
in which i would do
a 90 minute bout of work now why 90
minutes well
the brain is going through these
90-minute so-called altradian cycles
throughout the entire day and night
every 90 minutes we shift over
from being very alert to being less
alert and then back to alert again
here's how it works
at the start of one of these 90-minute
ultradian cycles
my brain is not quite engaged in
whatever it is i'm trying to do
oftentimes i have things jumping into my
mind i've got distractions etc
i'll talk about how to deal with those
distractions in a moment but
i set a timer for 90 minutes and
i try and get a strong bout of work done
inside of that 90 minutes with the full
understanding that the entire 90 minutes
is not going to be uniform in terms of
my ability to focus there will be
kind of peaks and valleys within that
but that 90 minutes is about what the
brain can handle
in terms of a dedicated effort for high
degree of focus
some people can push out a little bit
further some people can't handle more
than 10 minutes but
that's what i'm striving toward you'd be
amazed how much you can get done in 90
minutes if you are focused so how do you
increase that focus and how do you
use the the timer feature well you can
combine those
i use a program called freedom it shuts
me out of the internet completely
so that means no checking the markets no
checking social media
no checking uh you know the the news
no checking email none of that i
get a dedicated bout of work done i
confess i don't allow myself to go to
the restroom in that period of time
here's an interesting little tip that's
grounded in physiology
you have a direct neural connection from
your bladder
to your brain stem areas that increase
alertness
this is why when you have to go to the
bathroom when you have to urinate
it is extremely agitating right it can
be
very very agitating i'm not encouraging
you to get
so agitated by filling your bladder so
much and resisting going to the bathroom
that you are uncomfortable and can't
focus
but i generally will just drink liquids
and work away and work away and i won't
walk away to go
use the bathroom unless i absolutely
have to sort of odd that we're talking
about this but this is one way in which
i've learned to funnel my attention into
whatever it is i'm doing
because as you all know the moment you
sit down to do some serious work and you
flip off the internet
all of a sudden it's as if the phone has
a voice it starts calling you it's
almost as if
the restroom has a voice but we all are
familiar with the fact
that if we are focused on something that
all that just kind of melts away so the
goal is to get into what i call the
tunnel to really get into a tunnel of
quality work
the brain loves that state but it's very
hard for many of us to access
my phone is absolutely off it's not on
airplane mode it's absolutely off during
this time
if i've been struggling with that and i
confess you know i there are times when
for whatever reason something going on
in life it's been harder to put away the
phone
i will sometimes put in my car i used to
joke that i used to throw it up on the
roof or something like that
look i've done and i suggest people do
whatever they need to in order to
self-regulate that activity and if
you're somebody that feels that you
absolutely need to be on your phone and
on the computer for this
workout or the work that you do well
that's a different matter altogether
this is just simply how
i work so i will do 90 minutes and i do
set a timer and i turn on the program
freedom locks me out of the internet
if someone rings it on the doorbell um i
will often shout
not coming to the doorbell leave it
there i mean unless there's a real
emergency
i'm not going to step away from that
work i learned how to do this when i was
a graduate student
under different conditions where i used
to slice brains on what's called a
microtome
so i used to spend time just cutting
very thin slices it's like a deli slicer
but for a brain
of various types of brains and i've
sectioned through a lot of brains and we
had a rule
which is that when the blade hits the
brain you don't stop pulling even though
it's very very slow
even if a nuclear bomb goes off even if
a fire alarm goes off now i don't want
anyone you know
burning to a crisp because uh they
didn't step away from their workflow
that would be foolish but
that's the mentality that i've embedded
in myself that there's nothing more
important
than what i'm doing in that 90 minute
block and that's what works for me you
can
try various other things that's what
works for me
in addition i use low-level white noise
this is something that is supported by
quality peer-reviewed
data we covered this on the episode on
hearing and balance
but it turns out that white noise which
is essentially all frequencies of sound
we're all frequencies of sound that we
can perceive mixed up kind of randomly
there's no structure to it
turned on at a low volume not with
headphones most of the time
puts the brain into a state that's
optimal for learning and workflow
and i covered two papers during that
episode
one that showed that indeed brain areas
involved in attention
brain areas involved in focus and
cognition and memory
those are engaged to a greater degree
when there is low levels of white noise
playing in the background
the other paper that's really
interesting did brain imaging and show
the areas of the brain that
are associated with dopamine release are
increased by low levels of white noise
dopamine release is associated not just
with pleasure but with
motivation and craving so everything
about this 90 minute block from the low
levels of white noise to the position of
my computer
how i'm standing where my eyes are
positioned is geared towards putting me
in this tunnel of work
and i have to say that while it can be a
challenge to try and achieve this state
and this tunnel of
work some days you start to get kind of
addicted to it it feels
really good it's like a workout for the
mind and it is
something that as you exit that 90
minutes you really feel like you've
accomplished
a lot because often you have and it just
feels deeply satisfying and i'm
convinced that that's because of the
release of neuromodulators like dopamine
and the
norepinephrine that's circulating in
your system and i want to be clear that
i'm not perfect about this 90 minutes
occasionally i get drawn away
occasionally something will happen or
i'll
go use the restroom or costello will
have a need or somebody will have a need
that i'll
that i will have to respond to but i
really try to achieve this
most if not every day that i'm alive
because for me
that work session is kind of holy it's
where i cut where i set up a
relationship not just between me
and the work that i'm doing but between
me
and my ability to control my own state
of mind
using these various supports of the
white noise etc but really
those supports are peripheral to the
fact that i'm creating this space
i'm funneling my brain into a state
rather than allowing whatever events and
contexts on social
media and elsewhere might be occurring
in the world that would yank me out of
what for me is my purpose and my mission
in life which is to do the sorts of work
that i do
there's a powerful way in which you can
place the timing of this 90-minute work
bout
in an optimal way you have access to a
very important piece of data
that dictates when this bout should
start
more or less and when it should end
that piece of data is your temperature
minimum if you're somebody who wakes up
on average at 7 a.m
well then your temperature minimum is 5
a.m and
you can be reasonably sure i want to
underscore reasonably but you can be
reasonably sure
that your best work is going to be done
anywhere from
four to six hours after your temperature
minimum
so for me i tend to wake up around 6 30
a.m that means my temperature minimum is
at 4 30 a.m
you can add five hours to that so that
means that
a 90-minute work bout could fall at 9 30
a.m
and it would be fairly optimized or
i could do it at 10 30 a.m or i could do
it at 8 30 a.m somewhere in there
all right that we can't say that it's
exactly six hours after your temperature
minimum you will find it however
there is a precise and best time for you
to do this
90 minute work bout whether or not it's
five or six hours after your temperature
minimum is going to vary from person to
person
how do i know this how do i know this
relationship between temperature minimum
and focus cognition well temperature
minimum
defines the trough that the nadir as
they say of the
of your temperature across the 24-hour
cycle and immediately
after that your temperature will start
to rise
that temperature rise is actually what
triggers the initial cortisol release
that you experience and wakes you up
further and then of course that sunlight
that you're getting
is going to further enhance that healthy
release of cortisol
that cortisol will then provide fuel if
you will
for that increase in temperature and
your body will continue to increase in
temperature
throughout the day toward the afternoon
what you're trying to do
in this in this idea of optimizing this
minute workout to a particular time of
day is catch the portion of the steepest
slope
of that temperature rise now again
you're not working walking around with a
with a thermocouple or a thermometer
in some orifice of your body so you
don't have accurate information about
temperature
but you can make very good guesses about
when your body temperature is rising
fastest by virtue of that temperature
minimum so again just to be clear
it's a 90 minute workout that's about
what the brain can handle for a very
intense work bout
do understand again that they're going
to be portions of that 90 minute that
your brain is flickering in and out of
focus other portions where you're going
to be entirely focused that's entirely
normal
but when to place that 90 minute workout
when to start it and when to end it
will depend on that temperature minimum
so if you're somebody who
wakes up at 8 a.m each morning your
temperature minimum 6 a.m
chances are you're going to want to
start this work bout somewhere around
10 a.m or 11 a.m now
some people wake up and feel very alert
first thing in the morning they can
really do their best work
first thing in the morning please if
that's you continue to do that
leverage that time uh use that time but
if you're somebody who
struggles to find focus definitely let
your physiology
and this rise in your body temperature
support your efforts to focus
rather than trying to do your best work
at times of day when your physiology
is actually directing your body and your
brain toward defocus and towards being
more lethargic it just
is setting yourself up for success when
you try and capture this rising phase of
your temperature
so up until now we've been emphasizing
practices that allow you to optimize
your level of alertness
and your levels of mental focus
data going back to the 1990s
supports the idea that physical movement
of particular kinds
can support brain health and brain
function both in the immediate term and
in the long term
now this has had a profound impact on
the field of neuroscience
but frankly it's also had a profound
impact on how i structure my day
so after i've finished a bout of work
this 90 minute bout of work
i force myself some days other days i
want to but i force myself
to do some sort of physical exercise
that is going to be supportive
of my brain health and brain function
and organ health and bodily function in
general
so i just briefly want to touch on what
the structure of that
exercise looks like how it's structured
within the day and how it's structured
across the weeks in fact
based on the scientific data and what
the scientific data say is
best or optimal in order to promote
longevity of the brain
ability to focus as well as
cardiovascular health and all the other
things that we know exercise supports
now there are various forms of physical
activity or what we call exercise
but those can generally be batched into
two categories
first is strength and hypertrophy work
so
physical movements that are designed to
make you stronger and or make your
muscles larger
there's also endurance work physical
exercise and movements that are designed
to allow you to do
more work over time or to extend the
amount of time that you can do
work of any kind both physical and
mental
and we did two full podcast episodes on
the details and the science and the
protocols related to these topics
we did an episode on the science of
strength and hypertrophy of building
strength and muscle building
and that included a lot of protocols and
we did an episode on
endurance how to build any one or all of
the four types of endurance
which are muscular endurance anaerobic
aerobic long distance endurance etc
so if you're interested in the specifics
of those protocols please see those
episodes
however right now i just want to
emphasize how the data
impact my day and how i structure my day
in a way that i can incorporate
physical movement in a way that supports
my brain and health
basically after i finish that cognitive
work about that 90 minute workout
i do some form of physical exercise for
about an hour
the data all point to the fact that
working out hard for longer than an hour
can actually be detrimental because of
the way that it raises cortisol
and cortisol can be a good thing if it's
appropriately timed and in the
appropriate low levels
but you don't want to have your cortisol
levels up throughout the day or have big
spikes of cortisol
repeatedly so keeping workouts
relatively short can definitely help
with that
and certainly if you're training hard 60
minutes or less
should be more than sufficient and for
many people including myself 45 minutes
or 50 minutes is probably even
more optimal the basic design of this
physical exercise
is that it be approximately 60 minutes
so maybe 60 plus or minus 15 minutes
should be
well within the margins of keeping
hormonal health proper and not going too
long
nor making the workout so short that
it's not beneficial
and essentially what the data tell us is
that in order to optimize cardiovascular
and brain health and other systems of
the body we want to
exercise at least five days per week i
know that seems like a lot
it certainly is a lot for certain people
some of you you
compulsive exercisers might gasp but the
idea of taking two days off i personally
find that taking two full days off per
week is actually both beneficial to my
uh exercise training performance as well
as a pleasant
i like those rest days but essentially
the structure
of the exercise regimen that works for
sake of supporting health is going to be
one in which there's a three to two
ratio
where for a 12 week period or so
maybe 10 to 12 weeks three of those five
workouts per week emphasize
strength and hypertrophy and the other
two emphasize endurance
then after 10 or 12 weeks one switches
over to a 10 or 12 week regimen of
doing a three to two ratio where you're
prioritizing endurance work
so primarily the sorts of workouts that
are described in the endurance episode
and those protocols and the other two
days you're focusing on strength and
hypertrophy work
merely to maintain strength and
hypertrophy to not
lose the strength and hypertrophy that
you've created
and there are a lot of data now
supporting the fact that maintaining
muscular health
and bone health is supported by
resistance training weight training
of various kinds can also be done with
body weight if you don't have access to
equipment
and of course that doing cardiovascular
endurance work
is very beneficial both to the muscles
of the body the organs of the body but
also to the brain
many of you have probably heard that
doing physical exercise of
various kinds can support the production
of new neurons in the brain
frankly those data are specific to
research animals as far as we know
increases in neuron number
are not supported by exercise in humans
there's a little bit of data that
supports that maybe a few neurons might
get created by
running or weightlifting or things of
that sort in human beings
but there's still a host of other
reasons to have this hour
or so per day where one is doing
physical exercise and those include
increased blood flow to the brain
remember the brain is an organ too it's
the most metabolically
demanding organ in your body and it's
receiving those metabolic factors it's
receiving its fuels by way of
vasculature
of blood vessels and capillaries and
veins and things of that sort
so movement is very crucial to get your
brain to function properly
movement of various kinds is very
important to get your brain to function
properly
resistance training turns out to be as
important as
endurance training because of the way
that it stimulates the release of
particular hormones actually from
bones things like osteocalcin which can
positively impact
brain function and can support the
health of existing neurons
as opposed to increasing the number of
neurons turns out increasing the number
of neurons
may not actually be as beneficial as we
think it all sounds great more neurons
more neurons
certainly more neurons is better than
fewer neurons than losing neurons
but incorporating new neurons into
existing brain circuitry is actually
very challenging for the brain to do
i make sure that after that workout i
get this
one hour or so of exercise five days per
week
because of the ways that it supports my
general health and there are now
hundreds of studies supporting the fact
that both
endurance work and strength training
or hypertrophy training done in
combination meaning not necessarily in
the same workout but done across the
week
is immensely beneficial for the
production of things like brain derived
no trophic factor
for limiting uh inflammatory cytokines
like il-6
for promoting anti-inflammatory
cytokines like il-10
provided that exercises of the proper
duration
and that it's not so intense that you're
actually creating damage
to the various systems of the body now
where is the threshold between
optimal sub threshold and
detrimental this is a this is a
complicated uh theme
if we don't put some structure around it
so let's put a little bit of structure
around it we already said that
about 60 minutes so 60 minutes plus or
minus
15 minutes is going to be optimal for
all these health benefits
what about the structure of the actual
workouts well
we need to address this issue of
intensity
a good rule of thumb based on the
literature and i discussed this with dr
andy galpin prior to the strengthened
hypertrophy and endurance episodes
and the literature that's published in
quality peer review journals really
points to the fact that
approximately eighty percent of the
resistance training you do
should be resistance training that
doesn't go to what they call failure
where you can't
actually move the resistance anymore
the other 20 can be of the higher
intensity to failure type training
now with respect to endurance work
one can build up endurance without
having to log
long long mileage or extensive mileage
in the pool or or by running
and that's because there are these other
forms of endurance that can build up
for instance the capillary beds within
the muscles building up the capillary
beds within the muscles will allow
more oxygen utilization within the
muscles and thereby will increase your
endurance both of the muscles but also
will improve
brain metabolism and the way that the
heart functions of cardiovascular
function
that 80 20 rule of less than failure
and work to failure in the resistance
exercise regime
can be transported or translated to the
endurance exercise
portion by focusing on that thing that
we're familiar with which is the burn
when we're running hard or cycling hard
we'll experience a kind of burning of
the muscles that's associated with
the lactate system during the episode on
endurance i
pointed out that that burn is not lactic
acid
contrary to common belief it is not
lactic acid
it's associated with lactate metabolism
and
again about 80 percent of the endurance
work should not incorporate that
so-called burn but if 20 of that work
or so i should say approximately 20 of
that work
does include that so-called burning
sensation
that burning sensation actually triggers
the activation
of release of certain compounds and
molecules from
glia this brain cell type that supports
neuron health
and actually the lactate system is its
own form of fuel for the brain
and so there's increasing interest in
generating
the lactate or pushing past that lactate
threshold for small
portions 20 or so of endurance work in
order to support
brain health and function so what does
all this all look like
as a protocol well as i mentioned before
this three to two ratio
so maybe you spend uh 10 weeks or so or
12 weeks or so
focusing mainly on endurance work three
workouts per week on endurance work 80
of those workouts meaning 80 of the time
you're below that burn threshold
you are not experiencing a burning
sensation but that for 20
of it you are that based on the
scientific data
should support lactate metabolism brain
health etc as well as cardiovascular
health and oxygen utilization all the
forms of
of endurance that we're aware of and
then the other two workouts would
involve resistance
training again with this 80 20 split
where 80
of the work is not to failure and 20
percent is and then maybe after 10 12
weeks you switch
where you start emphasizing strength and
hypertrophy work for three of the
workouts and
endurance work for two of the workouts
now of course some of you will be able
to train six days a week or you'll
compulsively need to train seven days a
week if you decide to do that
please be aware that this cortisol
threshold is a real thing so
for me the three to two ratio works out
perfectly because i like two full days
off a week
when i take those really depends on my
schedule and how i'm feeling sometimes
it's two days in a row sometimes they're
interspersed throughout the week
but in reviewing the scientific
literature for those two episodes
of the podcast and in talking to people
are really informed
in the world of resistance training and
endurance training and how that relates
to brain health and body health
this seems to be the most rational and
grounded protocol so that's the one that
i follow
so on any given day i finish that work
block and i
train i do some sort of resistance or
endurance training i put those on
alternate days or different days rather
so we've now talked about the ark that
spans
all the way from waking to a morning
bout of focused work to physical
training
i have not mentioned ingesting anything
or nutrients one of the most common
questions i get are what should i eat
for my brain
well ironically enough one of the best
things you can do for your brain is do
not eat
but of course we all have to eat sooner
or later and eating is wonderful i
absolutely love eating i even enjoy the
mere act of chewing
but the question of what to eat is an
important one as it relates to brain
health and brain function
before we talk about that i want to
emphasize that
training fasted actually has some
immediate and long-term benefits
prior to having my lab at stanford i was
down in san diego at uc san diego
and had an appointment at the salk
institute of biological studies
i had a colleague there by the name of
sachin panda he wrote a wonderful book
called the circadian code
he runs a serious biology laboratory
focusing on
metabolism circadian rhythms and so
forth as well as the effects
of fasting sachin
and his book the circadian code describe
how
engaging in physical exercise while
fasted can
amplify the effects of that exercise not
just for sake of increasing the
percentage of things like body fat
burned etc
but for cellular health liver health and
the
health of other organs so where possible
i do strive to do my workout
without eating anything first however
some days i'm very very hungry
and so i do ingest water
which contains electrolytes so that
means sodium magnesium potassium
for the simple reason that sodium
magnesium potassium
are required for neurons to function
properly it's part of
the way they generate electrical
activity
as well ingesting electrolytes for me
can quell hunger
and this points to a whole other topic
we could do another episode on at some
point which is
many times people think that their blood
sugar is low and actually
that's not the case and frankly one
wouldn't want their blood sugar to be
high you don't want your blood sugar
too low but you also don't want it too
high very low blood sugar
is terrible but low-ish blood sugar
tends to give us a sense of mental
clarity and focus
related to this adrenaline phenomenon
that we talked about earlier
in order to be able to focus on exercise
or work or anything else
you need sufficient electrolytes and so
many people find that if they
simply ingest some water with salt maybe
a 99 milligram potassium tablet
all of a sudden they feel very mentally
clear and able to do physical work and
mental work
so what i do is prior to this
morning exercise although it's now late
morning in this
way i'm describing it and typically it
does occur late morning i'll have some
water with either
so a little maybe half a teaspoon of sea
salt with
a 99 milligram potassium tablet or these
days i'm fond of taking
what's called element lmnt element i
learned about this from lex friedman's
podcast i know many of you are familiar
with lex
excellent podcast excellent scientist i
don't have any business relationship to
element
they're not a sponsor of the podcast but
element is
a product that essentially contains
electrolyte sodium
potassium as well as magnesium malate
which has been shown to
offset things like delayed onset muscle
soreness that form of magnesium doesn't
make people drowsy it's not an anxiotic
like some other forms of magnesium and
anxiety is just one that reduces anxiety
so whether or not it's element or
whether or not you're just putting a
little bit of salt into
some water and ingesting that prior to
training that can be an excellent way to
ensure that you're able to complete
the physical exercise um even though you
haven't
eaten anything and i confess some days i
will eat a little bit before my workout
just because i can't seem to resist
eating
i want to mention the use of stimulants
before physical training
this has certain benefits and certain
drawbacks
the benefits are sometimes it can
facilitate motivation because things
like caffeine
can increase the release of dopamine can
increase the release of epinephrine it
can reduce that adenosine level in the
bloodstream
so some people use caffeine before
training in ways that benefit them
it can also increase fat oxidation and
kind of fat metabolism and things if
that's your goal
i am not a particular fan of ingesting
stimulants before training
because of a whole set of problems
associated with most
forms of stimulants in the form of
energy drinks etc i am not a fan of
energy drinks i did
a decent portion of a previous episode
on food and mood on energy drinks and
some of the detrimental things they
contain
rather i try and train simply by
ingesting the caffeine sources i
mentioned before
guayusa mate some electrolytes
some water occasionally i'll have an
espresso or a cup of coffee before i
train
and on rare occasions i should emphasize
rare occasions
if i really need help increasing my
motivation or i decide i want to push
extremely hard i will ingest something
like alpha gpc alpha gpc
supports the release of a neuromodulator
called acetylcholine so 300 milligrams
of alpha
gpc has been shown to increase physical
performance but also cognitive
performance
some people might not be interested in
ingesting anything to improve their
physical performance
or anything at all but they might be
addressing how they can
improve cognitive performance and focus
and alpha gpc is a non-stimulant
way to approach that again definitely
check with your doctor before
taking anything or stopping to take
anything but alpha gpc has been shown in
various
studies to improve cognitive performance
and in people who have age-related
cognitive decline
there have been some positive benefits
reported in
quality peer-reviewed journals if you
want to explore those references please
go to examine.com go
please put in alpha gpc go to the human
effect matrix and there you can find
details of those studies references to
pubmed etc so let's talk about food
timing first
as i mentioned i eat my first meal
sometime around
noon plus or minus an hour for the
reasons we've discussed
the volume of food is also important
if you eat a large volume of anything
because it diverts
blood to your gut you will feel
lethargic
and you will have less blood going to
your brain that seems like a simple and
trivial fact but
if you want to be able to think you
can't ingest large volumes of anything
into your gut
so the discussion about what foods give
you energy is kind of moot
if you eat enormous volumes of that food
now the volumes are going to depend
on you and your needs and your activity
levels
i'm going to discuss what i do in terms
of
food content but i'm not going to
discuss food volume i
sort of know where that mostly full like
full line is and i usually eat a little
bit past that frankly
and i'm able to maintain a decent degree
of alertness into the afternoon and
that's my goal and i think that's the
goal of most people
to not work out in the morning or do
some
work and then just collapse into a
slumber that lasts all afternoon but to
be able to
generate alert calm focused states
throughout the day
so for lunch i do emphasize slightly
lower carbohydrate or low carbohydrate
intake
for the simple reason that adrenaline
and dopamine and their associated
neuromodulators are going to support
alertness so for me i fast up until
about
noon then i eat a lunch that consists
of some sort of protein thing like a
some meat or some chicken or some salmon
and some vegetables etc and if i've
exercised previously
which i do as i mentioned five days a
week then i will ingest some starches
i'll ingest some red or bread excuse me
or rice or
oatmeal and butter and nuts and things
like that i will consume
the various food groups as they say but
i will keep the total amount of
carbohydrate
a little bit on the low side or if i
haven't trained i won't have any
carbohydrate at all
not because i'm ketogenic not because
i'm anti-carbohydrate
not because i'm on a pure carnivore diet
far from it but because
starches cause the release of
serotonin in the brain and lend
themselves to a state of sleepiness
now i should mention that about 25 of
individuals
have genes that encode for enzymes that
allow them to eat large amounts of
carbohydrate
and not suffer from this lethargy this
kind of sedation from carbohydrates but
i don't have that gene and so
for me eating a new ish meal
that is not enormous but is decent in
size but that is mainly
protein healthy fats and low-ish
carbohydrates or no carbohydrates is
what allows me
to achieve heightened states of
alertness throughout the day which is
what i need for my purposes
so just knowing that meats and nuts
support alertness provided you don't eat
too much of them
that vegetables are healthy for us and
therefore we should eat them
and i happen to like them as well and
that carbohydrates tend to have a kind
of sedative
like quality to them that should help
you kind of
guide your food choices in an
intelligent way that's grounded in the
scientific literature
as it relates to alertness now what
about components of foods that are not
about alertness but are about mood we
did an entire episode on mood and food
and it's very clear based on now dozens
of studies
that ingesting sufficient levels of
omega-3 fatty acids
is going to support healthy mood and
even can act as an antidepressant
more than a dozen studies have shown
that ingesting
at least 1 000 milligrams per day of the
epa form of essential fatty acid
is as effective as prescription
antidepressants
in relieving depression and if you're
somebody who requires prescription
antidepressants
prozac's aloft etc it can allow people
to take lower doses of those medications
which in many cases is a
positive thing or a good thing to do
because of the side effect profiles that
many of those drugs carry
so i find these data remarkably
compelling
i mean here we have a food or a
substance from food
that can improve our mood and our sense
of well-being
and it does that by way of increasing
certain neuromodulators in the brain in
particular dopamine but also some other
related neuromodulators
so if you're eating fatty salmon
regularly if you're eating
krill regularly meaning if you're a
a whale if you're ingesting foods
that tend to have a lot of omega-3s you
probably don't need to supplement with
omega-3
most people are not ingesting sufficient
levels of omega-3s
and i'm certainly one of those people
despite an effort to eat good foods and
whole foods etc and unprocessed foods
i've made the choice to ingest at least
a thousand milligrams per day of epa i
do that in the form of fish oil and epa
dha
combination fish oil but the but the
threshold of a thousand milligrams is
not a thousand milligrams of
fish oil it's a thousand milligrams of
epa now for those of you that don't want
to consume
fish oils and prefer to get your
omega-3s from non-animal sources
there are non-animal sources various
forms of algae etc you can just
look that up online and you should be
able to find that there are also a
number of foods
that include these essential omega-3s we
did an episode on food and mood where i
go into more detail than you could ever
want
on that as well as some additional
recommendations
we also did an episode on thyroid
function this hormone that's important
for metabolism
and that pointed to the importance of
getting sufficient iodine which you
should naturally get from the salts
you're ingesting provided you're
ingesting enough salt
i'm not somebody who eats a lot of kelp
um
but or seaweed although i don't mind the
taste of seaweed i don't ingest it
regularly
but ingesting sufficient selenium or
selenium
has been shown to be important for
proper thyroid production thyroid
function which is why
i tend to eat a few brazil nuts each day
typically with my lunch or sometimes
before my workout doesn't really matter
the point is that the volume the amount
the content and indeed the ratios of
protein to fat to
carbohydrates are going to impact how
you feel and they're going to impact
your brain health
and of course the timing we know that
allowing periods of 12 hours or more
each 24-hour cycle where you're not
ingesting anything is beneficial for
your brain and body health that's what
sachin panda
and his colleagues work has shown over
and over again
in these quality studies so when people
ask me you know
what should i eat for my brain more
often than not
it's really a question of how you're
structuring your day when you're eating
for the first time how long you're
allowing yourself to fast each 24 hour
cycle
and also whether or not you're getting
sufficient omega-3s whether or not
you're getting sufficient
selenium to support things like thyroid
function which has an impact both on the
metabolism of the
body but also the metabolism in the
brain and when i say metabolism
i don't just mean burning energy i
actually mean the rebuilding
of things so in the episode on growth
hormone and thyroid hormone
we talked about how metabolism means not
just the breakdown
of fats and carbohydrates but also the
building up the repair of muscle tissue
the repair
of bone the reinforcing of bone and the
repair
and the buildup of brain tissue and so
those are the things that i emphasize
because they're
so strongly supported by the scientific
data done in
mice studies done in humans and
basically there's a lot of biochemical
evidence
that supports everything that i just
described along the lines of health and
well-being
i'd be remiss if i didn't mention
hormones hormones have
broad effects on the body and brain we
did an entire month on hormones if you
want to hear about
any of those hormones in detail we
talked about testosterone and optimizing
testosterone estrogen etc
sex steroid hormones which include
testosterone and
estrogen which of course are present in
varying ratios but in both men and women
and in kids they are manufactured
from cholesterol we hear about
cholesterol as this terrible thing but
they are actually made from cholesterol
and so if you don't get sufficient
levels of cholesterol
that can be problematic for your
hormones and that can be problematic
for your brain and your body health so
without
going into too much detail i'll just
point to
a couple things that i do that at least
from my blood work
and from my subjective experience have
been very beneficial for me that
some of you might want to consider first
of all
i am not shy about my love for butter i
will eat pats of butter directly
i believe if people are going to eat
cheese without a cracker i will eat
butter without a cracker
butter is high in cholesterol so i don't
eat a ton of it but at least for me and
for my
lipid profiles it's fine butter
has cholesterol which is a precursor to
the sex steroid hormones and
men and women need testosterone and
estrogen in order to feel good and to be
able to think
you do not want your estrogen too low or
your testosterone too low
so i eat butter in order to ensure that
i get sufficient cholesterol butter also
has some other things that are
beneficial
various small fatty acids that are that
are interesting
in terms of their effects on metabolism
etc
you can look those up benefits of butter
but again volume
is important and you can't overdo it
costello instantly loves butter as well
along the lines of hormones and
testosterone
get a lot of questions about this i
think because a lot of online
communities are sort of obsessed with
testosterone and
i just want to emphasize that yes having
sufficient levels of testosterone
is vitally important for brain function
and having sufficient levels of
estrogen will allow your brain to
actually function it turns out that
estrogen
is one of the main ways in which the
brain maintains longevity
and maintains its ability to think so we
should all be seeking
optimal testosterone levels for
ourselves both testosterone and estrogen
and many of the things that we've
discussed up until now morning sunlight
exercise fasting those can support
testosterone and estrogen in meaningful
and positive ways
i get a lot of questions about hormone
optimization we did
an entire month on this topic we did an
entire episode on testosterone and
estrogen optimization
i just want to briefly highlight two
things
that could be relevant and then if you
want more details please go see that
episode the first is that
testosterone can exert its various
functions only in its unbound form
free testosterone we all make
a particular binding protein called sex
hormone binding globulin
that essentially binds up testosterone
prevents it from being free
this sounds like a terrible thing but
actually it's a good thing because it
allows testosterone be transported to
the various tissues including the brain
where can it exert its various functions
for those that have lower than desired
levels of testosterone or too much sex
hormone binding globulin
it turns out that 400 milligrams per day
of something called tongat ali which is
a form of ginseng can actually help
increase levels of free testosterone
many people experience
a positive subjective effect and some
objective
effects as well meaning increases in
free testosterone when they do
blood analysis there are some data on
that not a ton in the peer reviewed
literatures and again
always approach these with a sense of of
caution and definitely talk to your
doctor
if you want to learn more about that you
can go to examine.com there's there's a
lot of
information there listed about that the
other compound that's relevant both to
men and women or i should say people
that are trying to optimize testosterone
and or estrogen
is fedoja fedoja agrestis is a
actually an herb that increases the
levels of what's called luteinizing
hormone luteinizing hormone is a hormone
that's released from the hypothalamus
within the brain
that travels to the gonads
either the ovaries or the testes to
stimulate the release of
estrogen or testosterone and fedoja
aggressive has been shown
albeit in a limited number of studies to
increase levels of luteinizing hormone
and thereby levels of testosterone and
estrogen in ways that
some people find beneficial so i just
want to mention those two and again if
you want a lot more information about
hormone optimization please see the
episodes on hormone optimization
a key aspect to the mid day meal
if you want that meal to benefit you is
to take
a brief walk afterwards it turns out
that brief walks of five to 30 minutes
after ingesting food
can accelerate metabolism and actually
can accelerate
and improve nutrient utilization which
is essentially the same as metabolism
but
nonetheless that's something that i do
after i finish
my noon meal i do force myself to stand
up
and go outside and take a brief walk
that also gets me again into optic flow
it also has another benefit which is
that i am giving my brain
and thereby my body more information
about light and time of day which is
always better than less information
about light and time of day
much of our circadian rhythm and our
health rhythms and all of our cognitive
rhythms etc
are supported by our cells knowing where
they are in time
and light is the primary zeitgeber
that's german for timekeeper
is the primary way in which the
body learns information or about what
function should be turned on and what
functions should be turned off so
getting that morning light pulse but
then also
leaving the house or apartment or
workplace and getting out for a few
minutes after lunch is beneficial for
metabolism
beneficial for nutrient utilization and
beneficial
for all the organs and tissues of the
body because you're getting that
outside light exposure now i'd like to
shift our attention towards
science-supported protocols
that increase the effectiveness in our
performance in
everything and by everything i mean
sleep i mean
physical performance i mean mental
performance
i mean less anxiety all the things truly
all the things and that is something
called
non-sleep deep rest non-sleep deep rest
or nsdr
is an acronym that i coined as an
umbrella term
to encompass many protocols that
all have been shown in one form or
another to support better brain and body
function
now these protocols have names that
you've heard before things like
meditation things like yoga nidra and
things like hypnosis
all of these protocols and these
activities however share something in
common which is
they involve a deliberate and directed
shift in one's state
and the shift tends to be toward a state
of
deeper relaxation we certainly don't
have time now to
dissect out the literature on all of
these there is ample literature
i should say there is robust and ample
literature supporting the fact that a
regular meditation practice is
beneficial
but meditation itself has many forms
transcendental meditation
loving kindness meditation third eye
meditation walking meditation
yoga nidra is a practice i've talked
about many times before which involves
simply lying down it doesn't involve any
movement no down dogs or up dogs or
anything it just involves
lying on your back and doing some
specific long exhale breathing there are
a lot of yoga nature scripts out there
that are quite good
but there's one nsdr type protocol
that has been shown by the greatest
number of scientific studies
to promote not just states of deep
relaxation
not just states of heightened focus but
also
to accelerate plasticity and learning
within the brain and that's hypnosis
and i've become increasingly excited and
interested in hypnosis
as a tool and not just a
tool of any kind but a tool that really
can be directed toward particular
goals and outcomes and i think that's
really what sets hypnosis apart as an
nsdr
non-sleep depressed protocol from things
like naps
or things like yoganidra or things like
meditation
and i certainly believe and understand
that meditation naps in yoganidra can be
directed
toward less anxiety etc but
hypnosis is unique in that it's
very directed the essence of hypnosis is
for the person you
to guide your brain toward a particular
outcome or change
so i'd like to point out a particular
resource it's a completely zero cost
resource
which is reverie.com that's r-e-v-e-r-i
dot com reverie.com obviously is a
website
where there are links to an app that's
available in apple and android
this is a hypnosis app but this isn't
just any hypnosis app this is a hypnosis
app
that contains multiple hypnosis
protocols
that are all backed by very high quality
science the science was done by
my colleague and our associate chair of
psychiatry at stanford school of
medicine that
david spiegel is responsible for that
work i'm not associated
with that scientific work they've
examined what brain areas get activated
during hypnosis
what the outcomes are for various
hypnosis protocols and within reverie
you will find hypnosis protocols for
enhancing your focus enhancing
creativity reducing pain
getting better at sleeping reducing
anxiety most of these are about 10 or 15
minutes long
some of them are extremely brief one
minute long they have a one minute
hypnosis that you can do
those one minute hypnosis scripts work
best if you've been doing
the 10 and 15 minute ones regularly or
semi-regularly
it's a really wonderful resource for
which there is a lot of peer-reviewed
published data
one study i'd like to emphasize in
particular is gang idol j-i-a-n-g
that is a reference you can find on the
reverie.com website under
our research and the title of this paper
is brain activity and functional
connectivity associated with hypnosis
and it was published in the journal
cerebral cortex
what this paper essentially shows is
that specific
areas of our brain that are involved in
executive function which is associated
with our ability to focus
as well as what's called the default
mode network which is sort of the way
that your brain idles does your
brain tend to idle uh at any at a level
of high anxiety or
calm as well as activation of a brain
area called the insula
that's insula the insula is extremely
interesting
hypnosis has been shown to activate the
insulin which
can enhance our sense of interoception
our sense of internal state
which might sound like a annoying thing
you don't want to be thinking about your
heartbeat or your breathing
but what's really interesting about
hypnosis is that it
increases areas of the brain that are
responsible for deep relaxation
focus and self-awareness this
enteroception simultaneously
and that's very unusual compared to
other states
and other states of any kind so i've
made it a practice
a daily practice in fact that after
lunch and after this walk
i do a brief 10-minute hypnosis script
because
what i found is that in contrast to
naps and in contrast to other forms of
nsdr it really allows me to enter a
state of deep relaxation
but also to then exit that state in a
very focused and deliberate way that
allows me to lean into my afternoon
in an alert way in a way that i can
function and do mental work
and interact with people etc so there's
no brain fog there's no grogginess and i
want to emphasize that the hypnosis that
i'm referring to here
and that reverie provides is not stage
hypnosis this isn't
you being programmed to squawk like a
chicken or do anything against your will
this is you
teaching your brain how to access these
focused relaxed interoceptive states
this is also an extremely valuable
aspect to hypnosis because
it can increase plasticity the brain's
ability to change in response to
experience
it's essentially opening up pathways
that allow you to change your brain
in the ways that you want and it's very
directed toward particular
outcomes so i am an as you can probably
tell i am very enthusiastic
about hypnosis as an optimal nsdr
protocol and so i do that
every single day there are days that i
don't manage to do it for whatever
reason i forget or
interference from email or etc but that
is essentially how i enter
my early afternoon i do this post
launch post walk nsdr in the form of a
reverie hypnosis again a completely
zero cost resource to you there are
excellent data
all those data can be found on the
reverie site and you can also learn a
lot more about hypnosis and what sorts
of hypnosis protocols
might be optimal for you so if you are
looking for a science-backed zero-cost
very effective tool for getting better
at focusing better
at sleeping better at all the things
that i believe people want
i do believe that is the the best tool
that one can access at this point in
time
so then after i exit hypnosis i usually
give costello a little scratch behind
the ear and then i make sure that i
hydrate
hydration again is vitally important for
brain function
it's vitally important for all bodily
functions and i often forget to do it so
i've just sort of linked
the drinking of water to my hypnosis
practice as soon as i'm done
i hydrate and then i tend to focus on
another work bout
so this would be for me sometime around
2 30 or 3 o'clock in the afternoon when
normally i would be quite
sleepy and passing out however the
protocol of shifting my morning caffeine
to 90 minutes two hours after
waking as well as the use of this
hypnosis protocol has really allowed me
to move through the afternoon in a way
that i don't experience that dip in
energy
every once in a while i'll feel kind of
sleepy or kind of out of it but
i've been really pleasantly surprised
at the extent to which one can avoid
that afternoon dip if you do certain
things properly
prior to the arrival of two or three pm
now if you're a napper and you want a
nap
no big deal naps can be wonderfully
beneficial
here are the rules around napping
according to the sleep science stanford
has an excellent sleep clinic i
consulted with jamie zeitzer
my colleague in the stanford sleep
laboratory
as well as matt walker out at berkeley
whose name i'm sure
most of you are familiar with wrote this
wonderful book why we sleep
naps should be 90 minutes or less
and 20 minute naps are fine but not
longer than 90 minutes
and there are essentially two varieties
of people people for whom
napping interferes with falling asleep
later that night
and staying asleep and people for whom
the nap does not interfere
you have to decide who you are and if
you're somebody who
can nap and not have any trouble falling
asleep and staying asleep
later that night well by all means nap
just make it 90 minutes or less again
these 90-minute cycles are really a
vital
constraint that we should all obey if
it's 91 minutes
don't worry you won't dissolve into a
puddle of tears but if you're starting
to sleep for an hour or more in the
afternoon
that can be problematic if you're
somebody who can
nap for 10-20 minutes that's probably
better than getting a full 90-minute
cycle unless you didn't get enough sleep
the night before but you really have to
figure out what's right for you there's
a lot of variety there but that's
essentially
what the science says now whether or not
you nap or whether or not you do not nap
a key protocol for sleep health and
wakefulness and metabolism and hormone
health
is viewing light in the afternoon
so here's the reason for doing this
as we progress into the evening hours
there's a phenomenon where our retina
our eyes
become very sensitive to light such that
if we view
bright lights or even not so bright
lights
between the hours of 10 pm and 4 am
that is strongly disruptive very
disruptive
for our dopamine production it can
really screw up our sleep
and it's actually been shown in data
from david berson's lab
at brown university one of the foremost
circadian biology laboratories
as well as summer tars laboratory at the
national institutes of mental health
that viewing bright light or even not so
bright light
between these hours of 11 pm and 4 am or
even 10 pm and 4 am
can disrupt learning and memory can
disrupt the immune system
and can disrupt mood in very long
lasting ways
there are ways to offset that however
what i call your netflix inoculation
for those of you that like to stay up
late on the tablet or computer or
watching netflix
getting a little bit of afternoon light
in your eyes
somewhat counter-intuitively can prevent
this disruption of bright light later in
the evening at least
somewhat what do i mean by that well if
you view
light as the sun is starting to go down
so if you step outside around 4 pm 5 pm
again
what time exactly will depend on time of
year and where you are located
on our planet but as the sun starts to
head down
you don't necessarily have to see the
sunset it'd be lovely if you could
sunsets are beautiful but if you can get
outside and see the sun as it arcs
down or if you can't see the sun
directly get some sunlight in your eyes
in the afternoon hours so maybe 4 pm
ish and do that for 20 30 minutes maybe
reading outside or taking a walk
i walk the dog again that's my protocol
in order to get that evening light what
it does
is it lowers the sensitivity of your
retina
in the late evening hours which allows
you
to buffer yourself against the negative
effects of bright light
later at night now it won't allow you to
blast your eyes with bright light you
still need to dim the lights in the
evening
but there's a very nice study that was
published in scientific reports
that illustrates that if one does this
if you go outside and view sunlight
in the evening hours for anywhere from 5
to 30 minutes and i realize that people
have
a range of of constraints on their
schedule but from
5 to 30 minutes what happens is that
your melatonin rhythm
stays appropriate now we haven't talked
too much about melatonin but melatonin
is a hormone that is inhibited by light
it's actually prevented by light
and melatonin is the hormone that allows
you to fall asleep easily
now i'm not talking about supplementing
melatonin i'm talking about
melatonin that you naturally produce
from your pineal
so the protocol is very simple get
outside in the afternoon or evening
for 10 to 30 minutes take your
sunglasses off get some bright light
get some natural light in your eyes if
you can't do that
probably better to just stay with
standard artificial lights inside
don't crank them up but just start to
dim them
again this would be a time to avoid blue
blockers people are popping on blue
blockers at four o'clock in the
afternoon because you're worried that
blue light is going to disrupt your
sleep well
you're making your eyes more sensitive
to any light that you might see
later in the evening blue light or
otherwise so get that afternoon light
so what you'll probably notice is that
the optimal protocols
for optimizing your brain and body
health and performance and sleep etc
are actually really simple but just
because they're simple
does not mean that they are not powerful
in fact they are very powerful because
they leverage
the most powerful technology that exists
which is your nervous system
you know we always think about
technologies as devices and indeed there
are some wonderful devices out there
some people are really into tracking
their sleep and their sleep time if
you're into that great that's not
something that i personally do although
i keep telling myself that i
i should do that there are devices that
can
control brain waves and things of that
sort but what we are talking about today
are
really basic things that we can all do
that can steer our neurology
and our biology in the directions that
are going to support
workflow that are going to support
hormones that are going to support
brain function so this afternoon light
viewing is yet
another example of leveraging a
technology that you were born with and
that you will die with and that you will
have your
every day in between in order to tweak
the hormones of your system in this case
the hormone melatonin so that it's
released at the appropriate times and
not at
the wrong times because we know that
when hormones and systems of the body
are
well aligned with the 24-hour schedule
beautiful things happen and when they
are misaligned terrible things happen
sometimes those terrible things are
subtle at first but disrupting your
circadian rhythms
is really bad for every system in your
body
getting it right and as you can tell
getting it right doesn't take much
can really serve to quote unquote
optimize you when i say optimize i mean
it puts you into a better mood overall
better state for learning etc so get
that afternoon light as well
so at some point in the evening i eat
that thing that we call dinner
and while it feels sort of strange to
talk about my dinner
the reason i want to talk about my
dinner and what i eat for dinner
is that for me dinner of course is about
eating
i'll mention again i love eating but
also about optimizing
the transition to sleep and sleep so
obviously i eat foods that i enjoy
i'm not one of these people that will
eat anything or avoid eating anything
simply to benefit from that
i do enjoy food very very much and so
my dinner generally is comprised of
things that are going to support
rest and deep sleep and that means
starchy carbohydrates
it's absolutely clear that one of the
major ways that we can increase
serotonin which helps in the transition
to sleep
is by ingesting starchy carbohydrates
now i realize that starchy carbohydrates
are kind of a demonized term nowadays
everyone's anti-carbs but
you know we really should distinguish
between refined sugars and complex
carbohydrates and we did an episode
about this we talked about how refined
sugars disrupt
not just metabolism but they actually
disrupt some of the neurons in the gut
that sense fatty acids and amino acids
from fats and proteins
but those same neurons can actually
respond to sugar
and create a situation where you
actually start craving more sugar
because those neurons in your gut
communicate via a nerve pathway for you
aficionados
called the vagus nerve and a little
cluster of neurons called the nodos
ganglia
n-o-d-o-s-e node is ganglia so right
next to your uh the corner of your jaw
and can trigger the activation and the
release of dopamine in your brain which
basically makes you crave more sugar
independent of how something tastes so
when i say carbohydrates what i really
mean is
starchy carbohydrates non-refined sugars
and in the episode about food and mood
and metabolism as well i referenced a
really spectacular lecture
by dr robert lustig who's a pediatric
endocrinologist at ucsf uc san francisco
absolutely um spectacular talk you can
find it on youtube easily
where he talks about the science of
refined sugars
and this isn't in any kind of conspiracy
or paranoid way
this is really the medical and
scientific literature
so my dinner is carbohydrates and some
protein so maybe some chicken or fish or
something like that maybe some eggs
or sometimes just pasta or just rice and
vegetables
and that's because i enjoy those foods
but also because
i want to increase the amount of
serotonin in my brain so that i can
actually fall asleep that night
many people who are on low carbohydrate
diets struggle with falling and staying
asleep
and that's because it's hard to achieve
heightened levels of
serotonin which are necessary to enter
sleep
i should also mention that melatonin and
serotonin fall in the same pathway they
are related
hormones and neuromodulators we won't go
into their biosynthesis
now but essentially what we're talking
about is a system that's biasing us
towards rest and relaxation as opposed
to wakefulness
you might ask well can't i just take
serotonin can't i just take 5htp or a
precursor to serotonin or tryptophan
and indeed you can however many people
including myself find that when they
supplement with serotonin in the evening
or at night
that can cause problems in the
architecture or the structure of sleep
it can cause a lot of people including
me to fall asleep very fast sleep very
deeply for three or four hours and then
wake up
and have a terrible time falling back
asleep and that effect
at least for me has can last several
days it's really disruptive
so i don't like to supplement with
anything that is directly
dopamine or a precursor to dopamine at
any time or directly
serotonin or a precursor to serotonin
rather there are other things that can
enhance
the transition to sleep safely which we
will talk about in a few minutes
but the evening meal consists largely of
carbohydrates for that specific purpose
of generating a sense of calm
and of course carbohydrates are
delicious and because
i'm doing some physical training and
presumably you are as well i hope you
are because it's so beneficial
to one's health that's also going to
replenish
my glycogen stores which is the one of
the primary fuel sources for
moving one's muscles and moving around
and doing exercise as well as for the
brain and for cognitive function
so low carbohydrates uh throughout the
24 hour period are not something that
are attractive to me i realize that some
people will do much better on a low
carbohydrate or even ketogenic diet but
for me and i do believe for most people
creating a situation of maybe fasting
and then low carb or no carb diets
for states of alertness and focus at one
portion of the day
and then ingesting starch carbohydrates
for sake of inducing rest and relaxation
is a at least scientifically rationally
based
protocol it's grounded in real
neurochemistry it's grounded in things
that we can point to and say ah this
food substance
this thing can support my brain not
directly because it's some magic
substance that's going to make all my
neurons
you know extremely robust but rather
it's going to support
sleep which is perhaps the foundation of
all mental and physical health in fact
we can point to sleep as
the primary way in which we can ensure
our overall health including
our brain health so let's talk about
sleep and how to access sleep
how to fall asleep easily and how to
make sure that the sleep we have is of
sufficient duration
and quality one way to do that is to
leverage the drop in temperature that's
necessary
to fall and stay asleep so i mentioned
earlier
in the early parts of the day after
waking
our body temperature is rising and that
continues throughout the day and then
sometime late in the afternoon
our temperature peaks and then it starts
to drop
that drop in temperature of one to three
degrees
is vitally important for us to be able
to fall asleep easily
one way that we can decrease our
transition time into sleep
is to accelerate that drop in
temperature and one way to accelerate
that drop in
temperature somewhat counterintuitively
is to use
hot baths hot showers or if you have
access to one a sauna
now this is counterintuitive because
you'd say well hot bath so it's going to
heat me up but actually
if you were to get into a sauna or a hot
shower or hot bath and then get out
your body is going to engage particular
mechanisms for cooling itself
off that are going to allow you to drop
your temperature more quickly
and fall asleep more easily this is why
many people find that falling asleep
after a nice hot shower or bath or sauna
is
really really easy and really terrific
it's sort of a
natural state that follows hot baths
saunas and showers
so how would you do this well we did an
entire episode on this topic as well the
use of sauna for sake of growth hormone
release if you want to check that out in
all the details you can
look at the episode on growth hormone
you will experience a growth hormone
release from sauna hot bath and hot
shower provided
they're done for sufficient duration and
sufficiently high temperature
for all the details of that please go to
that episode it's all laid out there
it's all time stamped it's all captioned
in english and spanish etc
but basically what we're talking about
is 20 minutes in the sauna
or if you're one of those folks who's
really chasing growth hormone release
you could do 20 minutes
then get out of the sauna for 10 minutes
and just cool off at room temperature
and then get back into the sauna then
get out
and then shower or dry off and and head
to bed
shorter bouts of sauna will work also
the longer bouts of sauna cooling sauna
cooling have been shown to lead to huge
increases in growth hormone and growth
hormone of course is involved
both in muscle growth but also growth
and metabolism of vault tissues
fat metabolism and repair of various
tissues so it's not just about growth
you hear growth hormone you think
hypertrophy but
the enhancement of metabolism and health
and repair and a number of tissues
so that's one way you can leverage heat
toward
the transition to sleep by the ways in
which exposure to heat actually cools
off your body
now let's talk about actually getting to
sleep and let's talk about behavioral
protocols first
it is absolutely true that keeping the
room very dark is beneficial
some people including myself have thin
eyelids and it doesn't take much light
to wake up the brain and body so keeping
a room very dark
is essential the other thing is keeping
the room cool you've probably heard this
before keep the room cool
get under warm blankets but rarely is it
discussed
why keeping the room cool is useful the
reason keeping the room
cool is useful for getting into and
staying asleep
is that throughout the night there are
phases of sleep where you are paralyzed
so called rem sleep that's a healthy
paralysis
so you can presumably so you can't act
out your dreams but there are portions
of the night where you can move and one
of the more important movements that you
do in the middle of the night
is put your hand out or your foot out or
you take your face out from under the
covers
as a means to cool yourself and you do
this while you are asleep
if you are in a cool room you can put
yourself under the blankets to stay warm
and then if you want to cool off you can
simply remove a limb
or you can toss the covers off entirely
however if you are in a room that's too
warm it's very hard
to cool off you would need a bucket of
ice water or
to get up and turn on the air
conditioning or something of that sort
or turn on the fan
so it's a simple but non-trivial way in
which
we can improve our entrance to sleep and
staying asleep so keep the room cool or
cold and get under warm blankets and
if you want to understand more about why
putting a hand out or a foot out is
valuable for cooling
i did an episode on the role of cooling
in something called heat dumping
or bringing heat into the body through
the palms the face and the bottoms of
the feet
you've got these portals these radiators
if you will
that allow us to bring heat into the
body and to dump heat
i don't want to go into the details now
but that episode is entitled supercharge
your exercise with
cold this is based on work that was done
by craig heller's lab at stanford
university
absolutely incredible data showing that
the proper use of
palmer cooling so the palms or the upper
half of the face or the bottoms of the
feet
can vastly i mean vastly increase
the volume of of exercise that one can
do and still recover from that
exercise and derive benefits from it but
this method of cooling for exercise is
grounded in a basic physiological
function
of our palms the bottoms of our feet and
our face which is to
dump heat or to allow cool to pass into
the body
so that's why in the middle of the night
as long as you're not in rem sleep if
you get too warm you put your foot out
or you put your arms out you're actually
allowing cooling of the body
through what are called ava's
arteriovenous astomosis is the technical
name
that are in the palms the upper half of
the face and the bottoms of the feet
and that's a very efficient way to cool
off your body so you do that
subconsciously
now there are things that one can take
to enhance the transition to sleep i am
not a fan of melatonin
for enhancing the transition to sleep
for a couple of reasons one
dosages of melatonin are far too high in
most supplements
melatonin can have some negative effects
on the sex steroid hormones testosterone
and estrogen
that's a serious concern third
melatonin's role during puberty or
around puberty is to suppress the onset
of puberty
so that's concerning i don't know that
people should be taking this hormone
that has all these other effects
the other reason is that melatonin will
aid the transition to sleep but it won't
keep you asleep and many people that
take melatonin find that they fall
asleep more quickly
but then they wake up unable to fall
back asleep
three compounds that can be very
beneficial for aiding the transition to
sleep and for which
there are wide safety margins although
please do check with your physician
before taking anything
are specific forms of magnesium
something called apogenin
and theanine magnesium comes in many
forms magnesium
malate has been shown to improve
recovery
from sore muscles for instance magnesium
citrate
is an excellent laxative for instance
magnesium
3 and 8 that's t-h-r-e-o-n-a-t-e 3-8 and
magnesium bi-glycinate
have transporters that allow them to
cross the blood-brain barrier more
readily than other forms of magnesium
and there within the brain they promote
the release of a
neurotransmitter called gaba which is an
inhibitory neurotransmitter which
shuts off the forebrain to some extent
it doesn't shut off completely but
it essentially shuts down thinking
rumination planning and then what we
call executive function
so for many people taking 300 to 400
milligrams of
magnesium by glycinate or magnesium 3
and 8 and there i'm referring to the
elemental magnesium for you aficionados
many people find that doing that 30 to
60 minutes before sleep can aid
them in falling asleep can really help
them fall asleep faster and stay asleep
some people however achieve some uh
gastrointestinal discomfort
from magnesium and therefore should
avoid it
magnesium iii nate and magnesium by
glycinate
for many people work however and when
coupled with apogenin and theanine
provide a sort of synergy or a sleep
cocktail
that seems to be very effective in
aiding the transition to sleep
so apogenin is the substance that's
found in chamomile
and 50 milligrams of apogenin taken 30
minutes before sleep
can act as a another way to shut off the
forebrain
and reduce rumination reduce anxiety and
allow people to
fall and stay asleep i did a podcast
with
dr daria rose she's got an excellent
podcast that i highly recommend you
check out covers a number of different
health scientific
and other subjects and she's a phd in
neuroscience terrific scientist etc
she's a big fan of apogenin as mi and
then the third compound is theanine
t-h-e-a-n-i-n-e
theanine is a compound that
can also increase gaba but also
increases activation of something called
chloride channels chloride channels are
another way in which neurons turn
themselves off or turn each other off
not turn each other off in the in the
way they were typically heard like that
turns me off but turn them off and shut
them down lower their lower their levels
of activity
so magnesium three and eight are by
glycinate epigenin
and theanine in combination can be very
effective
for aiding the transition to sleep and i
realize that not everyone wants to take
supplements
i certainly am not pushing any of these
i would hope that
everybody be able to fall asleep easily
and stay asleep for the duration of time
that they want without any supplemental
help
but i do think it's important to point
out some things that lie somewhere
between doing nothing
and taking prescription drugs because
many of the prescription drugs
associated
with sleep and you all know what those
are
carry other side effects they can create
bad dreams
um often very disturbing dreams they can
be addictive or at least habit-forming
they can create grogginess in the
morning some are safer than others
there's a variety of them out there
but for those that want to explore
supplements and how they can impact
sleep this combination of about 300 400
milligrams of magnesium threonator
or by glycinate 50 milligrams of
apogenin
and 100 to 200 milligrams of theanine
alone or in combination
have been beneficial to many people and
there are excellent studies
to support those statements again i
suggest you go to examine.com and look
up
the human effect matrix for each of
those compounds and you can explore them
one of the more interesting aspects to
magnesium 3 and 8
and by glycinate is that it seems to
have some neuroprotective effects as
well there aren't many studies on it but
the few studies that are there
point to the fact that magnesium 3 and 8
and magnesium by glycinate can also
support
neuron health and neuron longevity was
just an added bonus in my opinion
now what if you wake up in the middle of
the night this is a very common
occurrence
and there are two general themes around
waking up in the middle of the night
that one can use tools to counteract the
first theme
is if you're somebody who is tired in
the evenings and you're kind of pushing
yourself to stay awake
so you're going to the party or you're
pushing yourself to study your work
when in fact you'd like to get into bed
at 8 30 or 9 and then you're falling
asleep around 10 30 11 and waking up at
2 30 or 3 in the morning and you can't
fall back asleep
chances are that your melatonin pulse
was initiated
early in the night so that melatonin
pulse started probably around
8 30 or 9 but you're staying up you're
battling that melatonin
and then sometime around 2 30 or 3
in the morning that melatonin is no
longer present at sufficiently high
levels in your bloodstream
and you're waking up you're getting your
morning cortisol pulse shifted
into those wee hours of the morning
you may not like this advice but one of
the things that you can do to offset
that is to simply go to bed
earlier by going to bed earlier you're
going to get
the longer duration of sleep but i
realize that there are social reasons
and work related reasons why going to
bed at 8 30 or 9
is not necessarily beneficial to your
life
so in that case you might be one of the
rare individuals for whom
getting a little bit more bright light
in the evening could be a good thing so
this would be around the hours of 7 or 8
p.m and then that way causing that pulse
in melatonin to be delayed because
again light inhibits melatonin
now the other thing is many people wake
up in the middle of the night
because of anxiety or because they have
to use the restroom
it's perfectly fine to flip on the
lights but keep the lights dim
but if you flip on those lights try and
flip them off as soon as possible and
try and get back into bed
and if you have trouble falling asleep
again and you absolutely need to sleep
that's where these nsdr these non-sleep
deep breath protocols can really be
beneficial
even though the ns the non-sleep part
might make you think that they will
prevent you from falling asleep
rather than trying to fight your mind
trying to fight anxiety
which is always a terrible thing to do i
always say it's very hard to control the
mind with the mind
look to the body and that's what nsdr
scripts do things like yoga nidra
even the sleep hypnosis done in the
middle of the night if you wake up and
want to fall back asleep oftentimes
will help you fall back asleep
immediately
and if they don't they will at least put
your brain and body into a state of deep
relaxation
that more closely mimics the sleep state
that you ought to be in
than the awake ruminating stressing
about the fact that you're not sleeping
state so if you wake up in the middle of
the night really try and get back to
sleep and if you can't do that
by doing for instance long exhale
breathing which can work
use some other tool of the body to shift
the mind and
the tools that i'm recommending are of
the non-sleep deep breast variety
so now we've essentially traveled around
the clock
so to speak from the time where one
wakes up until the time
they start working until the time they
exercise
eat lunch do an nsdr head to sleep
get to sleep maybe wake up get back to
sleep etc
i want to emphasize that although
people's schedules vary
most people are doing more than one or
two work bouts per day and indeed i'm
doing more than
one or two work bouts per day i really
emphasize that
morning 90 minute work block because i
think
most people would agree that there's a
portion of each day in which we need to
do
the hardest thing or the most important
thing or the thing that demands the most
of our
cognitive self i position that early in
the day and i position
everything around that in order to
ensure that it happens
and that it happens with the highest
degree of efficiency and yes i make sure
that it happens
every day and that brings about two
other important points first of all
we do have this thing called weekends
and uh i tend to take one day off per
week not both
much to the dismay of people in my life
and costello
but nonetheless there is something
called weekend drift which is that
we can be very regimented on a monday or
a tuesday and then
even if we're good about maintaining a
schedule wednesday thursday friday et
cetera
most of us i would hope would alter
their schedule somewhat on the weekends
in order to recover
and get some additional rest and i want
to emphasize i
absolutely do that i take one day per
week where i go
full costello where i essentially do
nothing in a structured way
at least if i have my way i'm not making
any plans
i'm completely free to explore what i
want to do
and when i want to do it that's not the
way life works out oftentimes there are
social engagements and other things
that get in the way or that i enjoy and
that breaks up the day
but i do take rest i don't think that
one has to follow the same schedule
every single day however i do think
there are a few things that people
should do
every single day if possible and
those are get morning sunlight because
if you don't your circadian rhythms and
your health etc and your mood are going
to start to drift
and to try and get sleep on a regular
basis
and of course some of the greatest of
things in life happen
after 10 p.m and some of those even
involve sleepless nights
of various kinds i certainly don't want
to discourage people from
having a social life or from having a
robust party life if that's your thing
or for
uh for enjoying life because that's
certainly one of the main
uh things that we should all be pursuing
is to enjoy life
the only point i want to make about
sleep is that if you happen to stay up
late
it's still best to get up at your
regular wake-up time it's a very simple
solution to a problem that a lot of
people have
which is they stay up until two or three
in the morning and then they tend to
sleep late and then it tends to disrupt
their rhythm
try on most days and most nights
to wake up at more or less the same time
and try to go to sleep at more or less
the same time
in fact i was talking to matt walker
about this recently and he was also
surprised to see these new data and i
was surprised to see these new data that
emphasized that if you get a poor night
sleep or if you're up late the previous
night for good reasons
many people feel like they just want to
go to bed early the next night but it
turns out that's not
the best thing to do for your immediate
and long-term health try and stay up to
the point where you would
normally stay up and then get to sleep
if you go to bed a couple hours earlier
it's probably not going to kill you
but try to not go to bed for instance at
6 pm because you were up the entire
night before that can really be
disruptive
the other thing i want to emphasize is
that even though that morning 90 minute
work block
is so vital of course there's a second
work block and in fact i described one
in the afternoon after the nsdr for me
that's reverie hypnosis
there's a 90 minute work block in which
i drop in
again in a no internet connection no
phone kind of way
to complete some work that's important
to me so combined that's just three
hours of focused work which
may not seem like a lot but if you were
to dissect your day and kind of look at
the ark and structure of your day
i'd be willing to bet that if we added
up the total period of time in which you
were
in what cal newport would call deep work
really focused dedicated work that it
would probably amount to about three or
four
hours if you can squeeze in another 90
minute work block or
if you can get four 90 minute work
blocks well then more power to you but i
think most people find that
one or two of these really deep focused
90-minute work blocks
are about what one schedule and even
mind can handle
and of course throughout the day there
are other things happening
outside of those 90-minute work blocks
i'm checking my text messages i'm
checking my email
i'm responding to various demands i'm
working
and tending to life so while i've carved
some boundaries or delineated some
boundaries around those work blocks
and i'm certain that if you do too you
will benefit from them
they are certainly not the only periods
of time each day in which i
or i believe other people should be
trying to learn or trying to focus
and i want to emphasize that even though
my job is to
discover knowledge and distribute
knowledge because i'm a scientist
i realized that 90 minute work blocks of
the sort that i'm describing
may not apply specifically to the kinds
of work you do if you're an artist or a
sculptor
or you build furniture or whatever it is
that you happen to you teach children or
they teach you
whatever it happens to be of course
please
adapt and modify what i've described
today in ways that best serve
you and your schedule what i've tried to
do is provide you a picture of the
24-hour schedule that i follow and why i
do certain things
at particular times and why i do those
particular things and i've really tried
to emphasize the scientific rationale
behind those things
the peer-reviewed data in some cases i
pointed out the specific papers in other
cases i've referred to large
bodies of work that support these
practices when i say large bodies of
work
i'm a big fan of looking to the
scientific literature and asking where
is the center of mass for a particular
topic
for instance where is there 50 or 100 or
a thousand papers that for instance
support
morning light viewing in order to
optimize
melatonin secretion later that in the
day
cortisol secretion early in the day mood
metabolism etc
if one were to put into pubmed light
metabolism and mood you would literally
get
tens of thousands maybe even hundreds of
thousands of studies so when i say the
center of mass what i've really tried to
do
is examine the literature and figure out
where there's a sort of a directive
protocol that emerges from all these
various studies that used
you know in some cases animals in many
cases humans and explore different what
we call
dependent variables some studies we're
looking at effects on blood sugar
other on mood so i hope that makes clear
why the rationale behind what i provided
today
if you're learning from this podcast and
enjoying it please support us by
subscribing to the youtube channel
there at youtube you can also provide
comments and feedback
we use that feedback to inform future
episodes
in addition please subscribe on apple
and spotify
and on apple you have the opportunity to
leave us up to a five star review
as well as to leave us written comments
if you're not already following us on
instagram
please do there i provide short
tutorials on neuroscience and
neuroscience-based tools on a frequent
basis please also feel free to join our
neural network
the neural network is a free resource
newsletter that i provide each month
that has protocols and resources all
zero cost
you can find it at hubermanlab.com
during today's episode
i describe very supplements that one
might want to consider taking
we've partnered with thorn that's
t-h-o-r-n-e dot com
because thorn supplements are known to
be of the very highest stringency and
quality
when i say stringency in quality that
means the quality of the individual
ingredients as well as the amounts of
those ingredients match precisely
with what's listed on the packaging if
you'd like to see the supplements that i
personally take
you can go to thorn.com slash the letter
u
slash hubermann and there you'll see all
the supplements that i take and you can
get 20
off any of those supplements or any of
the other supplements that thorn makes
another great way to support us is by
checking out our sponsors
we only work with sponsors whose
products we absolutely love
and if you want to support us please
check out their websites the links to
those websites are in the episode
caption
and last but not least thank you for
your interest in science
you